[Music]
one of the most vexing aspects of
science is that for every problem you
solve
sometimes you create two more problems
problems you would have never
anticipated
such is the case with the big bang
theory the big bang model is
spectacularly successful
and it's about to celebrate 100 years of
successful
observations and confrontation with
theory the big bang model is
spectacularly successful
at explaining large-scale features of
our universe and yet
it still has its own gaps gaps that the
theory of inflation was designed to
solve
but inflation too has its own challenges
challenges that perhaps can be solved
with new models
models known as bouncing cosmologies and
that's what today's subject is all about
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
science is sometimes described as long
periods of boredom
punctuated by periods of pure terror
such is the case with the big bang model
which solved many problems
in the previously existing steady state
universe but
in turn for every problem that it was
designed to solve
more problems emerged problems that
we've talked about in other videos
today's video tackles problems that
inflation was purported to solve
and yet inflation too like the big bang
like almost all of science creates new
problems for each one of its successes
come along with me today into the
impossible to learn more about
alternatives to inflation and we'll find
out these have their own problems as
well
i've talked a lot in this channel about
inflation and how spectacularly
successful it is
i've talked about the motivation for
inflation and why we needed
something like inflation to explain the
lacunae the gaps in the big bang model
that was part of what inflation was
designed to do but inflation has
challenges too
challenges we've talked about first and
foremost among them the multiverse
issue that has been the subject of many
discussions on this channel
with each one of the big bang's
successes comes a challenge
the successes are manifold but there are
flaws as well
perhaps equally significant the biggest
challenge to the big bang
in many cosmologists minds is the
so-called singularity
that is thought to have initiated the
big bang itself
where all the matter in the universe all
of cosmic
energy and matter was perhaps compressed
into an infinitesimal point at such a
point
in the absence of a good theory for
quantum gravity all hell breaks loose
so it would be nice to have a theory
that makes the same
large-scale predictions of the evolution
the composition
and the large-scale properties of our
universe that doesn't rely on a
singularity
to get the whole thing started off i've
described in this channel how inflation
shouldn't be thought of as the cosmic
genesis event
inflation is spectacularly successful at
explaining the large-scale features of
the universe including its structure
its flatness its the so-called horizon
problem
the absence of magnetic monopoles it
also makes concrete predictions that
there should exist at some level
possibly observable possibly not as
we'll discuss in future videos
of so-called tensor perturbations also
known as b-mode polarization
that was the subject of my book losing
the nobel prize in the so-called bicep2
incident
we'll talk more about experimental
techniques that pursue cosmic inflation
in future videos but there are problems
in inflation as well
most models of inflation are tacked on
to a theory
of the initial conditions of the
universe aka the big bang itself when
perhaps time
came into existence and these usually
involve so-called singularities
many inflation models also feature what
is known as quantum runaway by its
detractors aka
the multiverse problem discussed in this
video over here
we're not going to go back and recover
that ground again
suffice it to say there is much
controversy as to whether or not
the multiverse is not only a problem for
cosmology but all of science since it
predicts
an essential infinity of possible
universes
there's also a fundamental problem that
we'll talk about regarding the low
initial
entropy of the universe that is a video
that you can look forward to as well
but the question that we're going to ask
today is can
inflation with all of its successes
be replaced with a big bounce
which is another way of saying a smooth
transition from
an early state of our universe into an
expanding state that matches most of the
large-scale features of the big bang
cosmology
without requiring the so-called
multiverse
dimension we've talked about
alternatives including sir roger
penrose's conformal cyclic cosmology
and even hinted at other explanations
such as the ecpirotic theory
of paul steinhardt neil turrock and
others that involve brains and extra
dimensions
robert brandenberger my former
co-advisor at brown university
he has a model known as string gas
cosmology supported by other
cosmologists as well and uh and it is
noted that in many of these alternatives
to inflation
they generate problems that are already
in conflict with observations
such as so-called non-gassianity or they
require some sort of very fine tuning of
the initial conditions
required during the contracting phase
but are these features generic
do they occur in all collapsing and all
expanding
are all bouncing universes do they all
require spectacularly fine-tuned
conditional conditions it's not clear
the cosmological models that we're going
to describe today in bouncing
cosmologies
really only relies on the most simple
ingredients scalar fields which exist in
almost all cosmological models
and for which we have one example only
in the higgs boson
but also the mere ingredients of the
einstein equations
shown here there won't be a quiz on this
as
is my want however i call your attention
to the description as einstein
formulated it back in 1915
and that was that the left side of this
equation describes how gravity affects
trajectories it changes the metric of
space time
we only need three dimensions of space
one ordinary dimension of time
in the bouncing models of aegis and
steinhardt the right hand side of the
einstein equations
is equivalent to the matter energy
content of the universe sometimes called
the stress
energy and that will include things like
scalar fields matter
radiation and the matter can be dark
matter or ordinary matter
with these tools we can explain how a
bouncing cosmological model
can generically predict the geodesic
completion that is required to
describe how particles how matter and
energy evolve through this
classical balance we don't need a
quantum event
so we can avoid the cosmic singularity
that plagues the big bang in other words
how do we reconcile the existence of one
infinite point in cosmic history where
infinite temperature infinite density
rained
with the observation that nothing in
nature is infinite density temperature
pressure etc
of course the bouncing model must also
have the successful
predictions that inflation does namely
it has to resolve the horizon problem
explain the smoothness and the flatness
of the universe it has to explain the
absence of magnetic monopoles perhaps
it also has to generate the successful
predictions of so-called super horizon
scale
density fluctuations these are the
fluctuations in the curvature
the small-scale curvature of space-time
that later will seed
reservoirs of dark matter which will
then seed reservoirs for ordinary matter
gravitational potential wells to fall
into that we can later have
structures like galaxies clusters
planets people
and podcasts we also need to generate a
mechanism to
suppress the amplitude of b modes of
tensor fluctuations
in the early universe we also would like
such models to
avoid the problem of the multiverse
sometimes called by the authors
quantum runaway and we also have to
explain
we would like to explain the theory
successfully considered to be so
would have an explanation why the
entropy and the onset of the expanding
face not the big bang not the
singularity
now we're just talking about the moment
at which the universe began uh expanding
after a previously
collapsing condition why was the entropy
low at that stage
so that the arrow of time could point in
the direction of increasing entropy to
get to where we are today
the main features of the bouncing model
really revolve around this figure
declared uh by the authors to to be a
really simple
kind of diagram that they call a wedge
diagram we're working through it not in
great detail but we're going to explain
in the what follows how it represents a
solution that does not
need the conditions of inflation to have
a singularity
to have a multiverse and other issues
and yet it still
is consistent with the observation of
the universe
being expanding and cooling since about
13.8 billion years ago
it also has to explain the emergence of
complex structures today
because it came from a condition in the
early universe that was remarkably
smooth
about a time when the cmb was produced
the universe is about a thousandth of
its current radius
and the last scattering surface shows a
deviation from almost perfect uniformity
at this tiny level that we've talked
about in previous previous videos
with an rms of amplitude of only about
one part and 10 to the fourth
incredibly smooth so any viable theory
has to agree with these observations and
has to explain how the smoothness occurs
on large scales
and flatness as well but also explain
the small-scale anisotropies that grow
into the density of fluctuations that
produce
galaxies and planets etc so the authors
visualize
this diagram this wedge diagram and they
really only rely on two parameters what
we cosmologists call aft
and that describes the scale factor it's
a dimensionless quantity
that demonstrates how much a patch of
space changes in size due to the
expansion or contraction of the
observable universe
corresponds to some radius today the
hubble radius
and we can also characterize another
parameter the so-called hubble parameter
whose evaluation at the present time is
the hubble constant now the hubble
parameter generically speaking is the
first time derivative
of the scale factor where you get the
scale factor from you get that from
solving the friedman-robertson-walker
equations i'll show those here
where do you get those those come from
classical einstein equations
we don't invoke planck's constant or
quantum cosmology at all in this
framework
so it's very attractive for its
simplicity and elegance it's basically
classical cosmology that we teach to our
undergraduates
and all the only two parameters we
really need to keep track of are how the
scale factor and the hubble constant
uh evolve or the hubble parameter evolve
with time based on the amount of matter
and energy density in the universe at a
given moment
so while the authors can consider a
series of
infinite cycles of of expansion
and collapse the collapse doesn't have
to be to a singularity so it can
actually occur for a very long time
such models have a long pedigree in
cosmology actually initially considered
by
uh tommy gold and others and rejected
because they failed to resolve the
problem what do you do with all the
entropy of the previous
of the previous cosmological epoch
during a collapsing universe
and that is less of a problem in a very
benign condensation almost not even a
collapse we shouldn't think of it as
anything near
a black hole or singularity so the
authors generically can consider such
models but for simplicity
they consider just a single cycle in
other words a previous
collapse and then an expansion after
this collapse which occurs at some point
they call the bounce
and again we can set that point
arbitrarily far back in time
so one of the issues of aegis and
steinhardt's model
has typically been this question of
geodesic completeness
whether or not every particle that is ex
participating in the expansion of the
universe
has a world line a past history your
world line is your own past history from
birth to
where you are now through a
four-dimensional space time
does geogessic completeness hold in
other words can you complete the
trajectory
back through the bounds arbitrarily far
back to
cosmic history in the limit that such a
cosmology is past
geodesically complete we can have such
well-behaved behaviors unlike
cosmologies according to the authors
that have a singularity because in such
situations
the singularity means that you can't
uniquely associate a geodesic with any
individual particle's history
one of the virtues of the bouncing model
is that by design
the energy density never becomes
infinite in other words there is no such
thing as a singularity
and it actually holds at all stages even
below the plank density
when quantum gravity would be expected
to make a large effect
to aegis and steinhardt this is a good
point because it actually
provides us an empirical test that you
could look for the large scale
properties of our observable universe
and rely on them to be insensitive to
any details of
quantum gravitational nature
[Applause]
now you might want to understand quantum
gravity as they point out
to understand uh the fundamental
unification of forces and fields in
physics
but we've also talked about in this
channel there's no guarantee
that there is a quantum theory of
gravity there's no law from of nature
that says you must have all forces be
unified it's just a desire
obviously because there is no singular
no quantum gravitational epoch in a
bouncing model
you don't have to explain the transition
from quantum to classical
that's a bonus if it can be achieved so
it's always classically evolving and
that's thought to be very nice because
we don't have to rely on a yet unknown
theory of quantum gravity
so what happens to particles in this
figure that they call figure 3
these particle trajectories spend an
infinite or semi-infinite rather period
of contraction
within a causally connected common
region a cosmological horizon
then there's a tiny interlude which is
finite in time both before and after
the bounce when the horizon size becomes
small so small compared to the patch
rather that most of these world lines
lie outside of the horizon
after that period the horizon size grows
fast enough
to re-enclose and encompass all
trajectories
to this day for most of cosmic history
though the patch was
corresponding to our observable universe
has been causally connected
which is a nice property of bouncing
cosmology
which then allows us to resolve some of
the classic problems in the big bang
model
we talked about how inflation resolves
it via this early period of thermal
equilibrium before this massive
expansion takes place
these models of bouncing or cyclic
models in this case
do not have such a horizon problem to
contend with
the horizon problem comes about in big
bang cosmology because the patch that
corresponds to our universe was never
connected in the past
and you need to bolt on this
inflationary growth exponential faster
than light growth
at early epochs not that time equals
zero epoch as we talked about but
sometime shortly thereafter maybe
a million planck times afterwards but
you don't need this in bouncing
cosmology
so the ratio between the horizon size
and the patch size that later becomes
our universe decreases
extrapolating back in time as the scale
factor
a of t decreases as you go back to
earlier and earlier times
now this behavior must change once you
get to
the bounce if you're thinking backwards
in time the horizon size grows
arbitrarily larger than the patch size
so there's actually no impediment the
authors claim to having a smooth and
uniform universe
therefore we can explain naturally both
this
problem that we call the horizon problem
and the smoothness of the universe
so the causal implications of this are
necessary
according to the authors but not
sufficient to explain why the energy
density distribution was so
smooth at the time of last scattering
380 000 years after the big bang and
that was an early portion an early
moment in our current expansionary phase
so how do you get to a very smooth
universe
at that time of last scouting smooth to
one part and 10 to the fourth
well you need some kind of mechanism to
do so and the bouncing
cosmology there is a mechanism
associated with the evolution of how the
energy density behaves
we're not going to get into the details
of the equations i'll show them but they
actually are not important for our
discussion
we can describe them qualitatively and
leave the quantitative details to the
interested
viewer to look up on his or her own so
this factor eta determines the ratio
of the different types of energy and
consequently will determine how entropy
behaves both before and after the bounce
and all that's necessary some weak
conditions on eta as described in this
paper
and that decreases much more during the
contracting phase leading
up to the bouncing phase then it
increases during the expanding phase
so actually again you're not thinking
about this collapsing like a singularity
in a black hole again the whole point of
this is
manifestly non-singular and in doing so
we can get rid of
these challenges that plagued the early
big bang model theory until inflation
came along but again
let's remind ourselves inflation is by
no means proven it has
some successes and has some challenges
and on this channel we're exploring both
the successes of inflation and the
challenges to it the new alternative
models to inflation
created i should add by paul steinhardt
who's one of the fathers of so-called
new inflation
it's interesting that one of the fathers
of the inflationary theory recognized
universally no pun intended as such
is actually one of the foremost critics
against inflation
and he has a very very interesting video
with more technical details
from the simon's foundation that i'll
put a link to over here so are there any
bounds on how the energy density behaves
well there are different epochs that we
need to consider the contracting phase
which there may be a bound on how much
it can actually change in order to
match the low energy entropy conditions
at the start of the next expansionary
phase after the bounce
but the average value the energy density
during the contracting phase
can be much larger than it is during the
expanding phase
so these two effects can make the
contraction uh
portion of the bouncing universe
paradigm a very powerful smoothing
mechanism
some call it a super smoothing mechanism
so that we can start off with a smooth
universe which otherwise
it's really hard it's almost another
fine tuning problem that inflation
predicts this expansion by e to the 60th
power the size of a the a of t
parameter the scale factor but it also
allows for tiny fluctuations they come
about for completely different
from completely different mechanisms one
the formation of small scale
fluctuations comes from quantum jitters
in the inflaton scalar field
and the flattening comes from the
overall expansion of the of the scalar
fields value
itself so it is is accomplishing two
things
crinkling on small scales and smoothing
on large scales but the timing has to be
just right if you get crinkly early on
then you inflate
you won't get the universe matching the
observations that we see today
so this contraction phase becomes a
very plausible mechanism to get a smooth
universe and
the authors claim the same arguments
apply to the flatness problem
since the cosmic curvature depends on
this ada parameter too at a very steep
power
it actually reaches the bounce the
factor becomes small
at small scales and spatial curvature
gets exponentially suppressed
basically you smooth out the flatness
and the small scale perturbations as
well
so how do we get small scale
fluctuations well like inflation
the bouncing model also features a
scalar field the scalar field has
tiny quantum perturbations which are not
associated with quantum gravitational
perturbations
these are quantum fluctuations
perturbation theory and a flat
background a flat space time and these
tiny fluctuations in
the equivalent scalar field produce
later super horizon scale much larger
scale fluctuations that were observed
initially by kobe in 1992
and have been observed subsequently by
many experiments that led
credibility to some process creating
from quantum perturbations not in
quantum gravity but in quantum
uh quantum field theory fluctuations in
uh
in this scalar field so this model
unfortunately in my opinion has to have
a scalar field you'd like for an
alternative to inflation
to not have to have a scalar field like
having to have something completely
different
and maybe it does and we'll talk about
that in the context of other models
and perhaps alternatives to alternatives
to inflation so
alternatives to the alternatives now how
do you convert the scalar field
fluctuations into density
also known as curvature fluctuations in
the space-time metric that then explain
the temperature variations in the cmb
providing the seeds for galaxy and
cluster formation
well this conversion of the scalar
fields quantum fluctuations the density
fluctuations
have to then match the observed
so-called parameters of the power
spectrum these are observations of
what's known as the scalar
power spectrum n sub s and its amplitude
a sub f
these are well-measured parameters from
the cmb and other
cosmic probes now the authors admit that
actually some of the first examples
in of bouncing models in the literature
produced a lot of different
unobserved phenomena from structure
formation
mostly called non-gaussianity it was
later discovered by
the current authors that it's not a
generic feature of all
bouncing cosmological models so that is
not a strike against
um the bouncing scenario uh it's not a
proof either
but the question is where do these
fluctuations come from the authors claim
this is model dependent in other words
it depends on your
initial model and so much effort and
energy has gone into inflation i think
it
behooves us as cosmologists to look at
models
alternatives to inflation with as much
scrutiny
because they're essentially trying to do
something for the betterment of our
understanding of cosmogenesis
this would actually have within it a
description of what you could plausibly
say is cosmogenesis
the next feature that's an important
prediction of bouncing models is that we
should not observe
tensor or b mode perturbations in the
cmb and its polarization
that would be bad news for me if i'm
studying it with experiments like the
simon's observatory right
but actually it's a testable prediction
that can be falsified by an observation
of b mode polarization by the simon's
observatory by sip array cmb stage four
and so in the balancing model the
contraction before the bounce
actually is going to suppress these uh
tensor perturbations
that lead to gravitational wave what we
call gravitational wave background
perturbations
they'll be exquisitely small in all
metal models of bouncing cosmology
they may be small in models of inflation
there's no guarantee that we can detect
them
but the tensor modes they are sometimes
called primary tensor fluctuations
are actually proportionately small to
the size of the hubble den
the energy density or the hubble
parameter is small at the bounce phase
so these models bouncing models make a
concrete prediction
there should be no observable b modes
primary what we call primary b modes
they also make the remark that late time
so-called secondary tensor modes
can be created when density fluctuations
re-enter the horizon
basically it's enormous amounts of mass
are moving with enormous velocities and
accelerations
generically they will generate
gravitational waves just like ligo
measures
but ligos black holes in spiraling black
hole gravitational radiation are not
indicative of something in cosmology
but those would be really suppressed
compared to what we would ever hope to
detect with experiments like the simon's
observatory
corresponding for you aficionados of a
tensor to scalar ratio of a part in a
million
far smaller than any goal of cmb stage 4
simon's observatory or bicep array
the last part that bears really strong
emphasis is that you don't need a
multiverse in the bouncing cosmological
models
the smoothing phase is the phase of
contraction
and it gives the impression that
according to the authors the evolution
should be uniform
but they also hint and warn that that's
only an approximation
quantum fluctuations on super horizon
scales can actually change how fast the
universe is contracting
before the bounce and can advance or
enhance
the smoothing and contraction phase so
in inflationary models most inflationary
models have the so-called multiverse
problem
and they claim that's associated with
quantum runaway when a gravitational
effect
can amplify the volume of rare large
fluctuations
and so you would expect in such regions
to be
very very smooth for very very long
phase
and get more and more rare fluctuations
in the inflationary models
so this doesn't occur in the bouncing
models and that's an important
alternative feature of them in the
bouncing models the analogous rare
fluctuations
are able to keep smoothing phases really
very smooth and creating patches that
are contracting
and balance out the number that are rare
expanding and that leaves smaller and
smaller volumes
gives them less time for these rare
fluctuations to take place
so you don't see a quantum runaway you
kind of have equal measures
of both large and small scale patches
and their growth rates are accordingly
well balanced lastly the small
entropy of the beginning of the
expanding phase can be explained
in bouncing cosmologies which is a very
strong feature in their favor
because the second law of thermodynamics
predicts that entropy density must be
increasing
so over 13.8 billion years of growth
with a known predictable growth rate for
matter and radiation since that time
the universe must have had very very
exponentially small entropy density
in its early phases either at the big
bang in the big bang or inflation
cosmology
or after the bounce so nowadays when we
think of inflation at higher and higher
levels
we have to look back in the future and
say that there must be a reason
why the entropy would be lower in the
early universe
there's no mechanism for that in
inflation it's usually established by
fiat called the past hypothesis
and in the bouncing cosmology the patch
that corresponds to our observable
universe today
was only a tiny infinitesimal fraction
of the horizon size
long long before the bounce so only the
limited entropy
of the pre-bounce phase is really
contained within the region of space
time which will then expand
and become our expanding universe that
we observe today
and in these models we can account for
not only the early expansion
but hopefully later expansion as well
that we witness in the dark energy and
accelerating universe phenomena that
we've talked about in this channel
so it's interesting the authors note
that in the
observable universe that we see today
it's actually only occupied a volume of
space time a few meters across
right after the bounce and so there's
only a tiny amount of entropy contained
in that few meter size volume
and that will contribute to the entropy
an observer would see one cycle from now
the rest would lie outside of the
observer's horizon
so i find this model very tantalizing on
many fronts
it's not without its own challenges as i
say it revolves around a scalar field
that has yet to be observed
and has some challenges not without
precedent inflation uses one as well
but having all the successes of
inflation described by a theory that
doesn't have a singularity
it's almost too good to be true i've
railed against singularities as kind of
motivated by this false hope that we
would have a unified theory of quantum
mechanics and gravity
but there's no letter from god that
suggests that it's guaranteed to be so
so a bounce model is useful in many
ways for one it's always good to have
alternatives it's not good to have
monopolies in science
nor is it good to have monopolies in the
marketplace as we know
so in cosmology typically today the 300
pound gorilla
is played by inflation and i think it's
interesting to have alternatives and
studied them
it also is interesting when those
theories come from creators of the
original model of inflation or the
the improved new improved inflation uh
that paul steinhardt contributed to
that also come with all the concomitant
knowledge of that model's challenges
but make new predictions as well in
other words it's one thing to complain
about the existence of the current
favored model and then it's another
thing to have a new model but it's even
better if you can do both
create a new model and understand the
lacunae in the previous model
the authors claim this is minimalist in
that we only need
a contracting phase with einsteinian
gravity
and simple stress energy such as a what
they call a canonical scalar field
with large kinetic energy density the
balance is smooth and classical we don't
need anything
like quantum gravity there is a
stabilization there is the
adherence to the null energy condition
and or
we we actually don't have to worry about
geodesic incompleteness
so these occur naturally in these models
according to the author and these are
occurring well below the planck scale
where quantum gravitational corrections
could become important so in a smooth
balance
we could have our our cake and eat it
too we could have a universe that
matches the observations that we observe
and cosmic microwave background and
baron acoustic oscillations
in late time evolution uh images such as
those of sanya zeldovich effect
measurements and
we can also have an explanation for the
existence of an expanding universe
coming from something not nothing as it
does
in inflation so i think it's highly
promising
it helps that it makes predictions that
we shouldn't see things i kind of wish
you know a personal venal perspective
that it would have some predictions that
would also keep us going on the simon's
observatory but it is interesting to
think
that we are well motivated with the
simon's observatory and we should shrink
strive even harder to look for these
imprints because
if we do detect b modes we will not only
motivate inflation probably beyond a
reasonable doubt but we'll also falsify
models
such as the cyclic theories of sir roger
penrose and these bouncing models
such as those of aegis and steinhardt so
the future looks very bright
even though the past may have been dim
and obscured our future is getting
brighter and brighter
and as i say with these types of models
we might be able to have our cake
and eat it too i'm brian keating
chancellor's distinguished professor of
physics and the co-director of the
arthur c clarke center
for human imagination thanking you for
going into the impossible
if you enjoyed this video you definitely
want to check out this playlist
with my cosmology friends talking about
the origin and evolution of the universe
and if you're interested in a deep dive
in the multiverse wormholes and other
exotic phenomena
click here and hear my conversation with
juan maldasena of the institute for
advanced study
enjoy and don't forget to subscribe for
more amazing content
you